a sure angel thanks so much for hanging
out with us via zoom today during
quarantine how are you hanging in I'm
doing good we're we're thriving out here
in Arizona but it's nice it's going
great I'm not going how are you how are
you in the family keeping busy I mean
well I mean it's funny because it's kind
of great because we're always on the
move but it's I said we had this time to
just be with each other and watch movies
together and bake food do all this fun
stuff together so it's nice it's nice to
settle down have you guys been doing all
like the family tick tock videos that we
keep seeing going viral and all that
every single day it's one of our
favorites so fun they can take talks
with the family we do like all this
crazy stuff together you'd be surprised
I love it we have been keeping very busy
during quarantine I feel like there's
like no downtime for you you released a
single at the beginning of April you've
got another one coming in May I mean
how has this time been for you
creatively it's been it's been actually
great because it kind of gives me a
second just to slow down and just like
to think about things like I mean we
haven't really used this time just to
like not do anything like it's like
we're constantly doing stuff whether
it's music video shoot whether it's any
photos or content or you know still like
promoting the song and while we're at
the house so we're still doing like a
bunch of stuff but it's kind of nice
just to like take a second at home and
just like reset yeah totally the video
or the song that you really enjoy this
one all day you have a video with it -
did you guys shoot that during
quarantine because it beautiful you did
we did we shot a little like visualizer
thing at the house and like the backyard
yeah right because it feels very
relatable like sweatpants in the back
yard like it's like not like trying too
hard it's just like I mean that's me
that's literally me like that's what I
wear every day it's like we want you to
wear this but it's like I and it's just
this is like my mind all day
Oh No her dead dead but that's like
that's the new norm
I mean we don't we're in unprecedented
times right now we don't know how long
this is gonna last and so our business
now
has been working from home and whether
it's doing interviews with this or you
shooting a music video out the back like
knows our have you had more time to kind
of sit down and maybe write new music or
think of you know maybe next steps for
you know how you want things to go
definitely I mean I've used this time
just to sit down write new songs I'm
getting to like catch up on those those
old things that I left and like wanted
to go back to so I can't go back to
those now and like I don't know make
them make them better and yeah it's been
awesome it's been like it's the time
that I need to just like sit down and
like the songs that I want to write in
my show it's like it's great
yeah no distractions you can't go
anywhere
so when you're sitting down and you're
doing these new songs and whatnot what
what's inspiring you well like I said
you make the best of like the situation
that we're in so it's like I felt like
it was because like everyone's stuck in
their house but it's just like one of
those songs where you're in the car with
your friends even though you can't happy
but you just even if it's like in your
garage right you're just jamming the car
you turn on the music and it's like one
of those songs that just brings like a
big smile of your face just like all day
I think about you you just like it's
like just one of those songs that you
want to vibe - and like it's just like
makes you happy and in this I am
everyone's kid to be smiling so listen a
holiday and hopefully puts a smile on
your face that's what I'm trying to do I
love that you just mentioned like lyrics
all day think about you is that
something that's going on right now
especially being away from your
girlfriend for sure yeah what's Annie
with my family yeah it's it's it's it's
been like 40 days I'm used to seeing I
like a couple days like that's weird
like that's it's not okay
this is the longest you and Annie have
ever gone without seeing each other
Krister yeah it's been so hard I can
tell you like we don't we don't talk
most like we don't talk much to the
neighbor then she'll FaceTime you like
all night and this is like yeah it's um
it's okay that I mean we're starting to
like no we're making the best of the
situations
OOP have you cried yet and I cried it oh
my god no my mom gonna be like I want to
cry I have to cry yeah but I don't but
now some days so you guys have been
keeping in touch via FaceTime and that's
kind of the new norm for your
relationship now that's the new norm
abang said yeah long-distance
relationship everyone in the world is a
long-distance relationship with their
girlfriend with their friends yeah Bert
it's virtual relationships now yeah it's
like um what is it called
even though it was like virtual reality
it was still like yeah sure so the new
song coming out in May then I mean you
you are not stopping you're not slowing
down
so what's the next single gonna be so
guilty comes out May 1st and we actually
shot the visualizer yesterday for it
like another music little like music
video for it um so that's fun we've been
doing that these past seven days just
because we have these beautiful sunsets
and they Arizona so we'll go on top of
it's gonna be like a beautiful shoe it's
like very like it's just gonna be like
stunning pretty much so I mean are you
shooting all these music videos well and
by all I mean the two that you've done
so far in your backyard I have you just
using an iPhone
that's a location expert he's been
everyone has a part you know what does
this quarantine is over you got to keep
them on you got to keep them out with
those job titles
it's just what's out coming for your job
it's a family affair take the show I
mean your family's always with you
anyway you know it's just so funny
because it's like I can just picture
your dad being like on location shooting
yeah he's on it
so guilty the song titled guilty tell me
more about this song what are we guilty
of I felt like the main reason why I
should release guilty for my next single
is because I think we did one thought
away we did all day and you kind of see
the evolution of it but with guilty it's
a completely new track like no one's
ever heard it it's a nice acoustic track
and it really does tell a beautiful
story I mean it's kind of heartbreaking
for the person that's tough yeah but um
it's um it's a great song I feel like
that's really the music that I like to
make which is really exciting so we go
from a bop to like this heartbreaking
acoustics about the bots - so it's April
May so what's on tap for June then the
pressure is on I've just done I mean
more music I don't know we're gonna
release an EP and album yeah I mean we
have like a body of work you know I just
want to make sure that all my fans are
ready to listen to it I'm just taking it
really step by step like just keep
spilling a little singles maybe an EP I
know the EP is gonna be coming soon it's
just gotta figure out well we know that
nothing stopping you during quarantine
oh well you know you obviously you're
very busy with music and I wanted to ask
you about acting because obviously we
know that Shazam - who is in the works
but did you might start production on
that and then have to halt because the
quarantine we actually haven't started
seeing we were set to start in this
summer map so yeah we were I think of
September actually right mom
oh you want to see the new puppy Cassie
is that a professional give it away from
but no we were psyched we're set to
searching in the summer so it's most
likely gonna be post calling but we'll
see George George King George tell me
about possibly the script for Shazam -
have you wanted to read it hey George um
can you tell her about the script yeah
oh he said I'll meet ya what they said
buddy you got it he hasn't read it yet
oh my god that's so weird you haven't
read the script me either
so we're so excited for you though and
obviously hopefully you guys start
shooting and getting back into the have
um have you been keeping such with
Zachary during quarantine I have yeah we
have has access at his big big house big
land that he hasn't invited me to know
you can so has anybody he's like good
excuse because yeah yeah it's like it's
the only it's like the first thing I say
every time I call hey when when you get
inviting me out things like oh you're
loaded never just to get through the
call yeah I bet you're excited to
reunite with them you're sure I will be
crashing yeah I'm gonna say I'll just
wait I'll wait Instagram what's the
first thing you'll do when you see him
are you like a big house with no
invitation and be like hey and he's
gonna be so confused
we're shooting even starts yeah it's
like maybe we can just go over the
script together like hey I came all the
way here so we can like practice
together yeah it's like I've never met
you before I really need to just hang
out with you Morgan
we've never done a movie together before
I just I need more work in shop it's
great
love it oh my gosh alright we have a
couple like rapid-fire questions we want
to ask you about quarantine are you
ready ready hit me with it
alright what are your go-to quarantine
snacks or food go to quarantine zags
oh man it's hard ice cubes paid a lot of
good potato chips
takis I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go
with talking what Joe's are you binging
or streaming to pass the time um I was
watching walking I'm watching Walking
Dead right now it's really good I'm like
I started like I remember watching a
long time ago in the ribbons anything no
I was like on seasons five an hour more
like season nine something pretty good
oh you're doing great doing great yeah
okay what item in your closet have you
been rewiring all the time oh my god all
of them seriously all of them and I'll
tell my mom like a week later that I
mention wearing the same clothes yeah oh
okay all day what is your biggest tip
for self-care during quarantine how are
you doing face masks uh uh yeah I mean I
mean I feel like we have a bunch of face
masks but I haven't yet I'm sure what
I'm doing that tonight just Riley
sitting right next to you that you to be
honest itself Karen team I noticed the
ring on your finger and I saw it on one
of your Instagram posts is that is that
a ring of significance or just fashion
uh but no Annie gave me this ring I
think like five months ago I just had it
on ever since like a promise to each
other
I feel like I feel like I've had like a
front-row seat to your relationship
since the beginning how long yeah
containing a purgative what how long
yeah like a year in like two months
oh my gosh you guys made it through yeah
what's the biggest thing you've learned
so far in that year of being in a
relationship
oh my god I feel like just like I feel
like I've grown up so much
through the relationship I feel like
before I was like this I know I was like
this kid lost like I knew what I liked I
knew I want I didn't like expect to be
in a relationship and then I was there
and if like I learned so much all my
stuff like little things that I didn't
know that I did and now I know it's just
weird I just like noticing those things
[Music]
grow thank you so much for taking time
out of your day to chat with us and
thank you I love you guys yes they say
technology
[Music]